نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء
لرعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه
من شرق السودان الى عدد من الدول في
المنطقه اكثر من نحو عشره الاف من رعايه
الدول الاجنبيه تم اجلائهم خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه عبر ميناء بورتسودان وما
يقدر لاكثر من سته الاف غادروا عبر مطار
بورسودان الدولي الى وجهات دوليه مختلفه
ومع استمرار عمليات الاجلاء الا ان مئات
من الاسر السوريه واليمنيه ما تزال حتى
اليوم في انتظار استكمال اجراءات مغادرتها
للبلاد احنا مطالبين اكثر من نوع يتم
اجلانه احنا مطالبين من اي بلد يقعدوا في
الناس او يستضيفهم شكرا احنا بس بدنا ممر
امن من هنا الى الحدود السوريه وشكرا
البعض تفضل البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل
والحصر هنا واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه
على توفير دور مؤقته في ظل ظروف يحاول
الجهد الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه بورسودان
تخفيف وطاتها على العائلات والنساء
والاطفال الموجودين حاليا بشرق السودان
نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
لمتابعه المزيد
نبيا والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات